it's Tuesday September 13th I'm rob with
some daily news and there's plenty of it
so don't go anywhere in recent months
Pokemon go has taken over the world in
mobile gaming but now it's paying
playerbase has dropped seventy-nine
percent the thing is it's still the most
profitable mobile game according to
digital analytics company slice
intelligence in their report slice
intelligence states that despite the
game's July fifteenth peak Pokemon go
still managed to earn twenty eight
percent of all mobile game sales in
August behind it falls candy crush saga
with four point five percent meaning
Pokemon go has generated six times the
revenue of the second most popular
mobile game and if you're one of those
pokemon go fans that's moved on and are
looking for the next Pokemon fix
Nintendo has announced the Pokemon Sun
Moon 3dsxl this two hundred dollar
system comes out october twenty eighth
and does not include the upcoming
pokemon sun and moon game good news for
all you for is a fans out there the
forza horizon 3 demo is out and ready
for you xbox one owners can grab the 18
gig demo now or if your slave in at work
sign in to your Microsoft account and
cue that sucker up before is the horizon
demo will let you try out the
Lamborghini santuario ford shelby gt350
are as well as a few dune buggies you
can even play online with your buddies
in a free roam session even though the
game launches on both xbox one and pc pc
players will have to wait until the game
releases to try out the demo on a sad
but happy note wizard entertainment's
chris metzen is retiring departing as
blizzard entertainment senior VP of
story and franchise development Metzen
will be leaving the company after 21
years starting as an artist for warcraft
orcs and humans betsson continued on to
serve as a writer for warcraft 2 and
then kept on climbing filling roles like
the co-creator of diablo lead artist for
starcraft and most recently the creative
director for overwatch
regarding why he chose the word retire
metzen stated because i'm not going to
some other company or starting up new
projects now it's time to slow it down
rest lay around on the couch and get fat
well fatter a well deserved goal for a
truly great man if you remember the e3
teaser trailer of death stranding how
could you forget it good news we got
some hot deets speaking at Sony
Playstation spree Tokyo Game Show
keynote presentation the game's director
Hideo Kojima revealed the meaning behind
the game's title and logo apparently the
black lines falling from the titles
letters aren't liquid but cords Kojima
went on to explain that the theme of the
game is about how people are connected
by strands hence the title death
stranding he revealed the game will be
in the action genre and it will be open
world with a degree of freedom Kojima
spoke of once again having gamers
connect via online strands or elements
that are different to the usual
multiplayer teams the developer also
stated death stranding will be in 4k
resolution and will support HD are tuned
in to gamespot on September 18th when
the day Okajima plans to reveal more
about this weird weird game that's all I
got for you today thanks for watching I
hope you learn something today and be
sure to stay tuned tomorrow because I'll
be handling the news again see